So, continuing
in Al-Wajeez
in the chapter regarding najasaat, the
various types of najasa, the various
types of filth.
And those filth which are things that if
they are on your body or your clothing
or your place of salah,
then they must be removed in order for
the prayer to be valid.
A najasa is a type of filth that
compromises the validity of a person's
prayer. Now,
yesterday
and we are now starting to get into
the chapter regarding kayfiyat izalat
al-najasaat.
How we are to clean and remove these
filth. How do we purify
ourselves from these filth.
Now,
[Arabic recitation]
principles
that are going to help us to understand
the coming chapter.
Two principles.
Does anyone remember what the first one
is?
Huh?
Relativity. Very good.
That cleanliness is relative.
Cleanliness and purity is relative.
Meaning what is considered clean for the
floor
is different than what is considered
clean for the clothing, is different
than what is considered clean for the
body,
is different than what is considered
clean for the bottom of the shoe, or the
tail of the dress, or the bottom of the
clothing, or the top of the clothing,
correct? So, it is relative. This is
number one.
Number two.
Anyone remember number two?
That
purifying
a najasa
is not
need an intention.
And this is very important because what
this means is that
by any means
it is purified or removed, it is valid.
Okay?
If there is an act of worship or
something that we have been commanded to
do,
it needs an intention.
That means that it has to not only be
done, but done in the way that Allah has
commanded.
Here as well,
we have the way that the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
told the companions and taught them how
to clean
themselves from these various types of
filth. However,
the purification or the removal of a
filth
is not in itself an act of worship in
the sense that it does not need a
specific intention.
Therefore, we can summarize the
principle as
removing
any filth
is by any means
necessary. Whatever achieves the goal
of the filth being removed,
it is valid. It is acceptable. This is
such an important point.
Because
for instance,
the water we drink,
the water we drink from the tap water,
from the faucet.
This water,
where did it originally come from?
From the ground, from a cement. Yes,
yes, but I mean, how does it reach our
faucet? Where does it go through?
Filtration, right? It was once sewage,
wasn't it?
It was once sewage.
But then it is what? Filtered.
And one of the methods of filtration
is
using chemicals to fil- filter it.
Correct?
Because essentially, when we want to
purify
some kind of filth,
we need to add more water to it.
If we have a bucket of water that is
contaminated, how do we purify that
bucket of water?
We add more water to it. We add so much
water that it becomes diluted,
right? That's one way.
But
but this is not how the filtration is
done.
This is not how
most of this filtration is done. The
water that comes out of the faucet,
it is filtered, and then it is treated
by various chemicals and various things
that it's exposed to
to make it return to its original
nature.
So, after it goes through this process,
the end result, if you were to test it
in a lab,
chemically,
there's no
trace of filth in it anymore.
Is that valid? Is that acceptable?
Yes, that's acceptable. It's by any
means necessary.
We look at a narration such as the
statements of the prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam,
where he said that
the woman asked
She asked
about the menstrual blood on the
clothing.
And what did he say to do? He said, she
is to scrub it,
and then wring it out, and then rinse
it, correct?
Okay.
So, that's one way. What about if a
person had a power washer?
And were to power wash it out of the
clothing. Would that be valid?
But she didn't scrub it.
Is that valid still?
Huh?
It's valid. Why? Because we said by any
means.
By any means.
Okay?
A person
is supposed She is supposed to
he said to take it, to scrub it,
to wring it out, to rinse it. What about
if
she forgot it on the clothesline
outside,
and for 3 months it was subject to the
sun and the rain and the
wind and so on and so forth. When you
come and find it, it is what? It's
completely gone. There's no trace of it.
Does she still need to find the spot
even though there's nothing there?
And
scrub it and ring it and rinse it? No.
Right? Because if it needed an intention
and if it was an act of worship on its
own,
even if it wasn't there, you would still
go through with the motions.
But the point is to remove the najasa.
That's the only point.
Right?
So, two principles. I really need you to
memorize these.
Number one,
najasa cleanliness is what?
Relative.
Cleanliness is relative. What's
considered clean for the floor is
different than what's considered clean
for the counter, is different than
what's considered clean for your plate.
Correct?
Number one.
Number two,
cleaning the najasa
by any means
necessary, by any means that secures the
goal for us.
Once the najasa is removed,
that's all that is is needed.
These are the ways that the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam
told the companions during his time
how to do it, meaning the the bare
minimum of what is considered
acceptable.
But this doesn't mean that a najasa
can only be cleaned in this particular
way. This is the bare minimum of how a
najasa is to be cleaned, right? So, for
instance, when we see the narration that
if a dog
drinks or licks from the plate or from
the cup,
how are we supposed to clean it?
Seven times,
once with dirt. What about if you use
soap, dish soap?
Is that acceptable?
How do we know?
Which one of the two principles?
By any means.
Understand? By any means.
This is the point here.
This is an issue which the scholars of
filth have debated intensely, and this
is the final
point of that.
the author says, "Number one,
the first type of najasa and purifying
it is the
carcass, the skin,
the hide
of a dead animal.
The hide of a dead animal. So, a sheep,
a cow, something that is
dead, any dead animal, how do we
purify its skin and salvage it? Is it
salvageable?
Says, "The first is purifying
the hide of a dead animal by way of
tanning."
Tanning.
Right? It's a type of curing process.
You use the
a kind of chemical or salt they use on
it, and it's put out to dry in the in
the sun until
the hide turns from hide to leather.
Right? That's what leather is. It's It's
cured. This process is called tanning.
In Arabic, it's called ad-dibaagh.
[Silence]
He says on the authority of Ibn Abbas
who narrates that I heard the messenger
of Allah
say
any hide that has been tanned has been
made pure.
So, notice the word here. Any hide
any animal hide that has been tanned
has been made pure.
Right?
So, when you go to the store, leather
belt, leather shoes, leather whatever,
this has been made pure. How is it been
made pure? By tanning. Now, is this only
for animals which are permissible to eat
or is it for any animal?
It is a difference of opinion amongst
the scholars.
The majority of scholars
of the
say only animals permissible to eat.
However, a very strong opinion
is that it is any animal. And this
is what the heart feels most fond of. It
is closer to
that it is any type of animal.
However, if a person wanted to be safe
and as we said before, just because
something is pure or just because
something is permissible doesn't
necessarily mean that it is what?
Appropriate, right? Not everything that
is permissible is necessarily
appropriate. We will end with that
inshallah.
[Silence]
Salatul Fajr again tomorrow will be at
4:30 inshallah.